Adam:
The original Amazing Stories was
an iconic show.
Adam:
The idea that there was a
Spielberg bit of magic
Adam:
every week that would be in your
home
was like beyond comprehension as
a kid.
Boy:
What is it?
Well let's find out.
Eddy:
What I love so much about
Amazing Stories
is that it really opens up your
imagination.
Eddy:
Every week you're in a different
world.
Eddy:
Is it a ghost story?
Is it an alien story, like you
just never know.
And that was our goal for this
show.
Boy:
Look!
All the episodes have their own
themes and unique stories
about what happens when the
ordinary touches the
extraordinary.
Boy:
He said he was from World War
II.
Boy:
That's not possible, is it?
No, of course not.
Justin:
These episodes represent every
walk of life.
It's really an escape into a
world of wonder and possibility.
There are these great adventure
stories.
Edward:
They have a lot of heart
and they have a message beyond
the adventure at hand.
Dylan:
I love that each episode you can
get
wrapped up in an entirely new
world, entirely different story.
Sam:
Maybe all this always happened.
Maybe you were always meant to
come back with me.
I think it's so cinematic
and epic.
Don't you feel different,
strong?
These are stories that don't shy
away from complex human reality.
Someone's coming!
There are stories that move you,
stories about human
connection.
We gotta go, now!
It really makes your hair stand
on end.
Car, move!
We're bringing back that same
level of magic that people
got when they first started
watching Amazing Stories.
It was so much fun to craft
these episodes.
And Action!
Adam:
To do a ghost story and
to do an alien story,
Adam:
and to do a superhero story and
a time travel story and a romance.
We're really excited now that
everyone's finally getting a
chance to see it.
Girl:
Study it all you want, the
answer isn't up there.
Woman:
It's not written in the stars.
You're in control.
Sam:
Now, it's time for you to stop
looking.
Announcer:
On your mark!
Sam:
Your life is waiting.
Announcer:
Set!
Sam:
Go out there and get it.
(Music)
Sam:
It's your turn now.